habile prusse c'est un duel à 5 aussi
qui se profile pour ces élections
municipales bonsoir stéphanie rambo
c'est ce que vous êtes le maire sortant
de la commune vous serez candidat à un
troisième mandat vous qui avez été élu
pour la première fois en 2008 et vous
conduirez est la liste ensemble
allons plus loin vous indiquez pourtant
en septembre ne pas vouloir vous
représentez suite aux défections aux
nombreuses défections qu'il y avait au
sein de votre conseil municipal pourquoi
changer d'avis pourquoi y aller
finalement tout simplement sous quand on
est maire d'une ville
moi j'ai travaillé sur un projet en deux
en 2008 tout est long tous produits tant
il ya déjà des choses encore à faire ça
c'est la première des raisons la
deuxième des raisons on voit et beaucoup
ne le dise le deuxième mandat le mandat
qui vient de passer de 2014 à 2020 a été
extrêmement durs donc il ya eu des
résultats qui ont été obtenus sur la sur
la ville évidemment mais on se rend
compte que certaines promesses certaines
choses pourraient être faites et
pourrait mettre à mal ses différents
donc on rentre dans une période de
grande difficulté et je pense qu'un gars
expérimenté doit être là pour rester le
seul maître à bord et puis la troisième
des choses je dois je dois vous le dire
il ya tellement une personne qui ont
tout fait pour je ne me représente pas
moi j'aime pas qu'on décide pour moi et
donc j'ai voulu simplement dire je suis
encore là et si je souhaite partir un
jour c'est moi qu'ils décideraient ces
tensions que l'on a senti dans la
commune notamment lors de votre
cérémonie de voeux vendredi dernier il
ya aussi ces deux plaintes qui vous ont
visé pour harcèlement sexuel l'été
dernier qui sont toujours en cours
d'instruction actuellement ça ça ne vous
a pas fait hésiter dans le fait de vous
représenter
non parce que je remets en cause ces
différentes qu'un jeu remet en cause
tout ce qui a été dit il y a eu comme je
le dit d'ailleurs si vous étiez là lors
de la cérémonie des voeux il y à une
instrumentalisation il y à une manip
manipulation je la rejette en bloc c'est
pour ça que je suis là je suis mangou
savez je suis un maire qui dit la vérité
depuis 2008 c'est quelque chose dont
j'ai beaucoup de défauts sûrement mais
je dis la vérité et je n'admets pas
qu'on remette
en cause mon honneur et c'est pour ça
que je suis là et j'ai voulu aussi me
représenter des nomades et moi c'est en
deux sets et reims était important aussi
à le dire devant l'irresponsabilité de
certains élus qui étaient avec moi qui
sont en face de moi aujourd'hui qui ont
rendu leur délégation
et il n'y avait qu'une seule chose à
faire quand on aime la ville comme je
les aime depuis 2008 il fallait être là
fallait reprendre les rênes et
heureusement que j'ai repris sinon je
pense que la ville serait dans une
situation extrêmement difficile encore
aujourd'hui
quid de votre liste justement avec ces
départs vous vous évoquez au sein de
votre équipe municipale est ce que vous
avez trouvé l'ensemble de vos colistiers
ce que cette équipe est complète au lui
elle est complète et c'est une grande
satisfaction quand j'ai souhaité me
représenter repartir c'était aux
environs du 22 novembre
vous vous retrouvez vous regardez
derrière vous vous êtes tout seul est
donc la première priorité c'est
évidemment de constituer une liste
elle s'est formée relativement vite elle
s'est accélérée au début de l'année 2020
nous sommes 35 s'était ouvert le 24
janvier donc en deux mois la liste c'est
composer avec des gens qui sont avec moi
qui me soutiennent totalement qui se
reconnaissent dans le projet j'ai voulu
défendre depuis 2008 est le bilan que je
porte aujourd'hui vous étiez stéphane
rambaud le premier maire d'eysines vous
revendiquez la république en marche
l om a justement investir un candidat
qui sera face à vous pour ces
municipales ça veut dire que c'est sans
étiquette que vous présentez faso aux
électeurs organisation je me faire
présenter sans étiquette car c'est ce
que je défends depuis 2008 j'étais maire
sans étiquette pourtant j'étais membre
très actif de l'ump par contre je
défends des que j'irai une ville ça
n'appartenait ni à la droite ni à la
gauche quand on parler d'école de parcs
etc y avoir différentes sensibilités au
sein des ateliers il est impossible pour
ça que j'ai j'ai en 2014 giraud fait
exactement la même chose
aucune raison de changer ce de changer
cela et en 2020 je repars évidemment
sans étiquette je l'avais de toute façon
demander le soutien à personne ça c'est
important
et quand les gens me rejoignent je leur
demande simplement de n'être ni
d'extrême droite et d'extrême gauche ne
leur demande pas leur courant de pensée
ça ne m'intéresse pas ce que je veux
c'est qu'il de s'engager ce qu'ils se
mobilisent pour la réussite de la ville
à mes côtés gassion vos projets pour
villepreux qu'elles seront s'il est ce
que c'est pour suivre des projets déjà
lancés en lancer de nouveau pour ses
éventuels
mandat oui alors ça c'est une des choses
la gestion d'une ville c'est une suite
et on peut pas tous les six ans je
trouve ça d'ailleurs très très drôle
qu'on dit alors quel est le programme
que vous allez faire comme si tous les
six ans fallait absolument qu'on se
remette autour d'une table et très vite
on fasse une grande 10 pour séduire le
plus possible de gens autour de projets
on écoute les gens on y tient ce sera
bien pour vous et les gens vous disent
oui et on est très contents de cela et
on met une grande liste
moi je leur ai juste une petite une
petite remarque là dessus au cours de
mon premier mandat 2008 2014
il ya trois projets qui ont été faits
ces levés parc c'est la médiathèque etc
les premières acquisitions des terrains
de la pépinière et ben justement je ne
les avais pas mis dans mon programme
parce que ce qu'on demande aujourd'hui
un maire c'est pas de promettre promet
de promettre c'est de savoir s'adapter à
une situation de voir quelles sont les
opportunités et savoir ce qu'il faut
faire pour une ville donc il ya le
programme
c'est très bien moi je m'appuie sur le
bilan qui a été le mien que je porte
depuis 2008 et puis ce sera dans la
suite moi je ne vais pas arriver et
promettent des choses pour faire plaisir
aux gens comme ce que j'entends
aujourd'hui il ya des promesses qui sont
totalement irréalistes
elles ne pourront pas être fait tout
simplement ce que les finances de la
ville ne le permettent pas moi c'est la
suite quand je veut redynamiser le
village par un lieu qui sera à la fois
on va transférer l'école de musique
on va pouvoir mettre des animations à
pouvoir mettre des marchés on va
redonner de la vie et on va pouvoir dans
une autre zone de ce même endroit
pouvoir tester des choses sur un tiers
lieu il ya beaucoup de gens de ce
village qui nous disent vous ne pensez
plus à nous il n'ya plus de commerces
y a pas de commerce car n'y avait pas de
parking va justement il y à du parti
aujourd'hui et on va pouvoir tester des
nouveaux commerces qui vont pouvoir être
mises en place à des tarifs extrêmement
extrêmement compétitif et la même chose
pourquoi je l'avais pas fait avant
simplement c'est pour ça que ça a du
sens le programme que nous allons porter
parce qu'il fallait construire la
nouvelle école pour pouvoir justement
utiliser ce lieu pour faire autre chose
et c'est tout cela la cohérence du
projet que je porte c'est de ne pas
promettre des choses nouvelles pour
faire plaisir mais donner du sens à un
projet par rapport à ce qui a été fait
et par rapport à ce qu'il faut faire
dans les prochaines années
dernière chose en 30 secondes je sais
que c'est très compliqué vous êtes
matériel
vous êtes 4ème vice-président 50 en une
ville prêt à intégrer cette
agglomération au cours de ce dernier
mandat quel regard vous portez sur cette
intégration est ce qu'elle est
totalement réussi ce qu'elle est à
améliorer alors ça a été extrêmement
durs parce que moi c'est vrai je ne
viennent pas de là de l'interco c'est
quelque chose nouveau qui a été pour moi
pour la ville
j'ai mis du temps ça a créé quelques
tensions par contre aujourd'hui je
reconnais que les douze maires ont su
s'entendre pour porter un projet commun
saint quentin en yvelines est une
réussite moi je suis ravi d'être le vice
président en charge du budget et des
finances car je sais que c'est le nerf
de la guerre je suis ravie dadis
président est nettement bim de d'une
intercommunalité qui porte le
développement économique et
l'environnement eau comme priorité par
contre et pour villepreux c'est vrai que
nous n'avions pas cette histoire avec
vous nous sommes au nord nous sommes
situés au nord de cette intercommunalité
il faudra encore travailler pour que les
villes creuser un évident problème ce
sont réellement membres de cette
intercommunalité
c'est tout l'enjeu également faire mieux
connaître saint quentin en yvelines pour
les prochaines années
merci stéphane mirambeau maire sortant
de villepreux candidats pour ces
élections municipales sur scène avec la
liste ensemble
allons plus loin quatre autres listes
seront en lice face à vous celle de
votre ex adjointe sylvie se démantèle de
jean baptiste à monique et 2 valérie
bain et deux coureuses golgoht lab on
retrouve bien sûr l'ensemble des rendez
vous de campagne sur notre site internet
tv 78 points comme